had a reputation in the house as like
being a runaway now so every time like I
would start throwing my fit my dad would
just started throwing [ __ ] to me he's
like go ahead yeah get going yeah yeah
[Music]
a northern California mother of two was
sentenced Monday to 18 months in prison
would you like to show that with the
class
would you like to show what's so funny
with the class oh shut up dude let him
finish all right thank you
um she was setting someone into 18
months in prison for faking her own
kidnapping so she could get back to a
former boyfriend which led to a
three-week multi-state search before she
resurfaced on Thanksgiving Day in 2016.
is this a woman who said like a Mexican
lady kidnapped her that she was
kidnapped by the cartel uh I believe so
yeah we did this one this is well we did
it when it happened yes and now she's
[ __ ] getting the sentence I love it
this is the Poetic Justice that's what
we like though you said it was 18 months
18 months
she's probably gonna get out and that's
not enough man that's not enough right
that's what she [ __ ] the entire 18
years she made a whole affluent
Community believe that Mexicans were
dangerous yeah I don't know if this is
that one because it doesn't say but
maybe it is let's just assume was it an
orange
it was in Sacramento
I think the one we did that one was in
Orange County but I also you're right
that was Orange County you're right
maybe she got kidnapped in Orange County
yeah she resurfaced in Sacramento
maybe she got tried there because yeah
who knows got extradited thankfully
we're a trusted news source for
everybody out there who subscribed huh
absolutely and don't forget to click the
Bell so that you can get a real bad news
white with blonde hair what's that is
she white with blonde hair uh yes she is
does she have two eyes and a nose she
has two eyes and her nose yeah she's she
looks like you know she's like you know
you'd probably [ __ ] her but like you'd
probably [ __ ] her oh I know what you
mean then I know exactly what you mean
yeah oh no that makes a lot of sense
like a picture in my head this might be
her okay so so just to get the facts
semi-straight because we're a trusted
new source for everybody out there uh
can you explain exactly what happened
one more time she faked her own
kidnapping in order to go back to her
boyfriend to go back to her voice so
leave her husband she was with the guy
she's not even married she was I believe
she's married okay yeah she's married
and then but then she wanted to get back
with her ex-boyfriend and so she's like
oh babe I'm not kidding I don't [ __ ]
sex and then
yeah and then and then basically
everyone was freaked out and like her
family's freaked out because she has
kids and then they were all looking how
did she fake her own kidnapping
um she like beat she beat the [ __ ] out
of herself in the bathroom oh she like
uh so her and that dude conspired to
like she like hit herself with a hockey
stick or something oh [ __ ] and then like
she emerged like way later and like was
all beat up her clothes all tornado
walking like playing the role you know
selling it and then uh they find her and
because I guess she was jogging at the
time that she got she was playing the
role jogging oh like there's so many
other choices to to deciding to go
escape the person that you're with to to
somebody else for a couple of days too
and I thought I think there's so
but apparently they looked at her
history and she does this [ __ ] all the
time so she's extra dramatic Ally when
she was a kid she did it when she was a
teen like this whole like disappearing
act and like saying that something
happened to her like it's her [ __ ] Mo
so she has a some mental issues she's
like this like the Riddler but no one
[ __ ] with herself but when they look
back on it and see that she's done this
multiple times is it like she's
disappeared multiple times or if she
does this and has been found in this
terrible way multiple times you know
where she's clear I think this would be
a piece to resistance but she's like
went levels into that yeah like she's
had like do you feel like she's gotten
better over the years at disappearing
and coming back this one was pretty good
it got a lot of people tricked pretty
good it tricked a lot of people but also
it [ __ ] over like a whole Community
which sucks you know because her whole
story was that she got kidnapped by
these like Mexican ladies I remember I
remember yeah let's dive deeper into how
you think that that [ __ ] up in the
entire Community because she made she
made everybody [ __ ] an extra racist
like they probably already were but like
she made everybody like go oh Mexicans
are our community no [ __ ] they're
stealing our jobs and they're stealing
our way yeah and then and then she
refused to identify them later when they
when they found her and they were like
we can find her if you tell us like
describe what she looked like and she
was like no I don't want her arrested
like she made this whole like other
story about like having some empathy for
a kidnapper Stockholm syndrome yeah she
said that Dave fed her chimichangas
and Lucas
and Lucas yo kidnap
s
have you guys ever ran away from home I
tried but I [ __ ] failed what was your
multiple times what was that your
youngest age did you last
um because I'm stubborn especially as a
kid
um the first few times not so long
um what was the game plan
the I think the last time I did it I was
there for like a good three months holy
[ __ ] where'd you go you actually did it
yeah I just talk a lot where did you run
to yeah how old were you what was the
game plan I think I was
17. oh wow
um my mom and I were just butt heads
give us the dates give us the dirty
Deets
um and it was just like things that led
up to it
um nothing
too specific but yeah I ended up just uh
running away with a guy that I was
seeing at the time and stayed at his
place for like three months three months
did she know that this guy existed yeah
do you know where you were yeah so she
knew where he lived too yeah I was like
10 minutes away from my house oh did she
ever try to come get you back or
whatever like dude no
um wow three months I think I think at
this point because I had done it so many
times it was just the last straw and it
was more so if I wanted to rectify the
situation I would have to come back and
apologize yeah
did you ever like have to sneak in at
home to get you like your phone charged
or some [ __ ] because oh no I was like an
Android
you're like how am I gonna survive
no I was pretty thorough and grabbing
all my belongings what about your first
time how old were you in your first time
um
15
[Music]
the car holy [ __ ] dude you're a renegade
yeah you're pretty good I just told my
parents I was like six years old and I
was like I'm running away from home and
I and then I made it to the street and I
was like damn I can't cross the street
this [ __ ] sucks
I remembered across the street yeah I
was like damn it I can't question
what am I gonna do Never Gonna Last yeah
yeah I wrote a Manifesto like on a giant
cardboard I was like eight and I wrote
this like whole Manifesto but like Ryan
was dissatisfied with this like currency
it was a review yeah it was like a whole
[ __ ] thing and I put it up in the
house you did in third person too that's
some crazy yeah I did a third person I
like wanted to do like a record of it
and then I [ __ ] started walking and I
didn't really have anything I started
walking around and then this like lady
started walking behind me and she was
like oh I didn't know that like is it a
school holiday what are you doing on
here and I was like
went back home I was like
yeah that's all like that that's like my
one experience I was like I'll never do
that again man she almost got me yeah I
got busted earlier than even getting out
the door I remember me and my sister we
had a go bag but we were kids so like
what does it go back for a kid crew roll
up Treasure Trolls our favorite blankies
yeah you know because you're like oh
dude you're gonna need yeah you needed
to I have my truck in there my little
Tonka truck hey tight Starburst I think
we did bring like toilet paper and a
toothbrush because it just made sense
because that's smart that's actually
pretty yeah it was just in this backpack
right and we put it like under the stair
closet just as far back as possible I
remember me and my sister come home one
day and then my dad's got the bag I was
like what is this right but it wasn't
like a he knew what it was it was just a
genuine curious like hey what is this I
remember being so [ __ ] scared it was
Elena's idea
for sure she was the younger one she's
older oh she's older okay well that
makes sense yeah it totally makes sense
did she whoop your ass after no no maybe
I might have deleted it from my memory
do you remember what the last straw was
in your life oh yeah I'm like I need to
have a go back ready just in case see
you know there's this thing that like I
remember this is gonna sound funnier now
as an adult but I'm my dad like he in my
mind he was very violent in my mind
right but what was he no I don't think
so because he would always pick up [ __ ]
and he would like Chuck it at me and my
sister right kind of violent but the
thing is in my mind it would be crazy
things it would be like the [ __ ] you
know like the Little Tikes table like
the yellow and orange one it's like big
stuff like things that like would kind
of put holes in like walls instead of
drywall and it would chuck it but
eventually after after a couple years
I'd be like how come this guy keeps on
shocking [ __ ] and he always misses dude
try throwing stuff
I don't think I was that good I just
think that at first I was like this guy
is [ __ ] shitty ass aim I'm like right
here he keeps not missing me but I feel
like it was just his way to scare me
without actually hurting me because if
you wanted to hurt me he would like slap
me you know it would be very intentional
I'm going to hit you with my hand or I'm
going to hit you with this [ __ ] why
is this so accurate this time yeah but
when he's very easy to take a [ __ ] Chuck
it next to me but I remember one time
you checked the [ __ ] table and I was
like in my mind but again it didn't hit
me yeah but in my mind I was like that's
it I'm done I was gonna get my go back
later I'm out of here this is so off
topic but I just remembered it so I uh I
was eating breakfast
um on the couch and my dad's sitting
there with his newspaper and I get up
super fast and I got lightheaded so I'm
carrying the plate to the kitchen I'm
like no I got this I'm a little
light-headed but it's gonna be fine and
uh next thing I know I'm just passed out
on the floor oh passed out I wake up and
I look at my dad he's still just sitting
there with his newspaper he looks over
here he's like you all right and I'm
like
what the [ __ ] the Plate's broken
everything's I was like
I mean I guess he's like cool really
that's killer that's a cold dad I was
like you're good like almost like it was
an inconvenience that I made all this
noise he's like hey we have to play
William when I was a kid that's what I
imagined white dads were like yeah yeah
exactly I'm glad it was correct and to
be fair though look how strong and
independent you are now right that was
it that's the reason look how
lightheaded you are a lesson that's the
how did you Rectify that how did you
come back home
um I think I just straight up came home
and just started crying and apologizing
wow yeah and your mom was like
yeah that's right she's like I knew
you'd be back or did she like meet you
halfway with you it was a halfway it was
a halfway point yeah that's nice that's
adorable we will never get that huh
I I didn't when I came back my parents
were like idiot yeah you didn't even
bring anything yeah they made me feel so
bad but like I had a
little I had a lot of
uh earning
privileges oh that's okay oh yeah yeah
earning their trust too right their
trust yeah like I didn't have my phone
like it was just like just rehab yeah
imagine Ryan coming back home they're
like no no no no here's your stuff you
go back out and try one more time my dad
used to do this like this time stay out
because then I had a reputation in the
house as like being a runaway now so
every time like I would start throwing
my fit my dad would just started
throwing [ __ ] to me he's like go ahead
yeah get going yeah yeah yeah yeah I
don't want to go yeah yeah it happened a
few times
[Music]